merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur jérôme chartier pour le
groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
hier la ville de domont à enterrer
nicolas katina il avait 37 ans j'étais
avec le préfet monsieur le premier
ministre et la ville de domont qu'une
petite ville d'ile-de-france 15000
habitants payent un lourd tribut
suite aux attentats à mort deux blessés
dont l'un toujours en réanimation et en
sortant de l'église
j'ai eu un double sentiment d'abord un
sentiment de tristesse
en réalisant cette vie brisée ce destin
qui s'arrêtait et puis j'ai eu un
sentiment de rage monsieur le premier
ministre
de rage contre celle disent ce que
j'entends qu'ils cherchent des excuses
aux terroristes et je voudrais vous dire
que les terroristes sont des minables
des assassins des sanguinaires qui n'ont
qu'un seul objectif c'est de tuer et
certainement pas un objectif d'une
quelconque idéologie aucune idéologie
seulement des assassins
monsieur le premier ministre j'ai trois
très simple question la première
question pouvez vous me dire nous dira
si tout a été fait depuis le mois de
janvier dernier pour prévenir la menace
terroriste
la seconde question vous l'avez dit hier
dix mille cinq cents personnes sont
suivies par vos services comme étant des
personnes radicaliser pouvez vous me
dire nous dire combien de ces personnes
travaillent aujourd'hui dans des
entreprises services publics
troisième question la semaine dernière
valérie pécresse a proposé que l'on
puisse accorder la possibilité de
licencier à ces entreprises de services
publics les personnes à radicaliser
êtes vous d'accord avec cette
proposition merci chartier la parole est
à monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
manuel valls le président monsieur
chartier vous avez raison d'abord de
rappeler que cette semaine notamment
mais pas seulement dans les jours qui
suivront le pays tout entier est bien
sûr d'abord les familles et les proches
des victimes n'est tué comme des blessés
vivront en communion communion
républicaine puis chacun dans son
intimité avec ses croyances
cette douleur vendredi prochain dans 48
heures c'est la nation toute entière qui
rendra hommage à l'ensemble des victimes
chacun d'entre nous d'ailleurs souvent
par une connaissance directement ou
indirectement aura aussi l'occasion
moment d'obsèques d'accompagner des amis
et proches de ses victimes et vendredi
le président la république le souhaite
la nation en n'accrochant en brandissant
aux fenêtres d'une manière ou d'une
autre le drapeau tricolore devra se
retrouver ensemble toutes les questions
qui sont posées par la représentation
nationale par la presse par les proches
des victimes par les français toutes ces
questions sont légitimes
quand on a connu une telle attaque une
telle violence de la part d'une
organisation terroriste d'une armée
terroriste puisque nous sommes en guerre
nous le rappellerons tout à l'heure à
l'occasion du débat sur la syrie quand
on subit cette attaque
l'organisation terroriste qui veut tuer
qu'ils tuent des hommes et les femmes
des jeunes parce que nous sommes la
france notre art de vivre notre mode de
vie notre culture qui puise ses
fondements dans le salafisme c'est à
dire la négation de toute culture qui va
donc au delà même de la destruction
d'hommes et de femmes
c'est une civilisation civilisation
quelle attaque en france quelle attaque
en tunisie l'attak aussi dans ces lieux
de culture millénaire centenaire en irak
ou en syrie donc c'est une une
mobilisation oui bien sûr le nombre de
victimes
monsieur le député en tunisie en france
hier en belgique cet avion russe qui a
été abattu oui oui il ne peut y avoir
aucune concurrence nous le savons c'est
toutes ces civilisations qui sont
concernés et donc la réponse elle doit
être à la hauteur et vous avez souligné
quelque chose qui me paraît très juste
hop une excuse
le doit être cherché aucune excuse
aucune excuse social sociologiques et
culturelles
tu as dans notre pays rien ne justifie
qu'on prenne des armes et qu'on s'en
prenne à ses propres compatriotes
bien entendu et de ce point de vue là
nous savons c'était une autre question
qui était posée
nous devons être non seulement un
pitoyable dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme mais aussi intransigeant à
l'application des lois et des règles de
la république
et en cette journée puisque sept
organisations terroristes s'attaquent
aussi un fondement de ce que nous sommes
l'égalité et notamment l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes
je veux dire combien doivent être
respectées les lois qui concerne
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
et notamment combien doit s'appliquer
la loi qui a été voté par le parlement
que j'ai voté et qui interdit la burqa
dans l'espace public
bien évidemment
alors il avait posé trois questions
la première est ce que tout a été fait
c'est en conscience
une question évidemment difficile car
moi pas je considère et nous considérons
que tout a été fait par mon gouvernement
et que tout continuera est fait par
rapport à une menace je ne veux pas
rappeler ici ce que j'avais eu
l'occasion d'annoncer le 13 janvier
en terme de moyens pour les services de
police et de gendarmerie pour nos
militaires pour la justice pour les
services de renseignement je veux pas
rappeler la loi sur le renseignement qui
a été voté à une très large majorité que
d'ailleurs on critiquait à l'extérieur
de cet hémicycle comme une loi
liberticide et souvent ce sont les mêmes
aujourd'hui commentateur qui nous
explique que nous n'avons pas assez fait
pour lutter contre le terrorisme et
qu'il critiquait cette loi ces lois sur
le renseignement
elle s'applique depuis le mois d'octobre
et une nouvelle loi y une proposition
loi a été voté aussi par le parlement
pour donner précisément plus de moyens
aux services de renseignement pour
suivre un certain nombre d'individus à
l'extérieur de nos frontières met en
confiance nous devons faire plus et
encore davantage
c'est ce que nous disent non seulement
les parlementaires c'est non seulement
ce que vous nous dites c'est ce que
chacun demande mais c'est ce que les
français réclament parce qu'ils ont peur
parce qu'ils ont compris
malgré les mises en garde de beaucoup
d'entre nous sur le fait que cette
menace était présente qu'il n'y a pas de
risque zéro que nous pouvons encore être
concernées par des attentats alors oui
monsieur le député nous devons continuer
à tout faire et sur tous les fronts et
tout ce qui concerne les fiches sc10
1500 personnes qui sont fichés par le
service d'enseignement nous savons c'est
un outil avec des situations
particulièrement différentes
nous devons et dans le cadre du dialogue
qui s'est engagé républicain avec le
ministre de l'intérieur et avec des
responsables des différents groupes et
je recevrai mois la semaine prochaine
comme nous le ferons régulièrement les
présidents des assemblées les présidents
d
commission concernée et l'ensemble des
présidents des groupes oui sur la
question de ce qui se passe dans les
services publics pas seulement sur le
thème de la laïcité mais sur la
difficulté que représente ces individus
il faut aller plus loin je pense que sur
toutes ces questions là nous devons
aller plus loin faire en sorte que
aujourd'hui ce qui représente un danger
pour la république soient poursuivis
pour que nous protégions les français
merci